- [Speaker] How many different species
or kinds of birds are there?
Take a guess.
100, 1,000, more?
Well, biologists have estimated
that there are at least 10,000
different species of birds
all around the world,
and some biologists think
that there are even more, up
to 18,000 different species.
Birds are incredibly diverse.
Think about the differences
between an eagle, a parrot,
a hummingbird, a duck, and a penguin.
Some of them are small and some are big,
and take a look at the differences
in their beaks or bills
and their feathers.
And not all of these
birds can fly, either.
Penguins use their wings like
flippers to swim underwater.
Collectively, these 10,000
plus different species of birds
are a product of evolution,
which is the change in heritable traits
that occurs in a group of
organisms over many generations.
But what are these
heritable traits exactly?
Heritable traits are those that are passed
from parents to offspring via genes,
and they include things like
the colorful patterns and plumage
or the webbing or toes
and claws of bird feet.
And even though offspring
inherit traits from their parents
and look pretty similar to them,
over many, many generations,
these heritable traits can change.
Evolution is made possible
by genetic variation
or differences in genes
within a population.
Genes are passed from parents to offspring
and they affect how an organism
develops, how it functions,
and even how it looks.
Genes can come in
different forms or alleles,
which can lead to different
versions of a trait.
For example, in city pigeons,
also called rock doves,
which you might see flying around,
different alleles cause
different eye colors
such as orange, black, and white.
Genetic variation causes
organisms within a population
to have a range of traits
like differences in plumage or eye color.
Genetic variation can come
from lots of different sources,
one of which is through
sexual reproduction.
This type of reproduction causes offspring
to have different sets of
traits compared to their parents
because they receive genetic material
from both of their parents.
In other words, the offspring
aren't an exact genetic
copy of either parent.
In this example of rock doves,
parents carry different alleles
that affect their plumage,
and, in turn, their offspring can inherit
different sets of traits
and may look quite different
from their parents.
Now, let's take a look
at that dove example
with the plumage differences
and think about it at the population level
with lots of doves.
You could imagine that
those plumage traits
can change over many, many generations
of parents and offspring
in a large population.
You might see new traits appear
like different colors or
different patterns and feathers,
or existing traits like dark colors
may become more or less common.
When this type of change occurs
or any change in heritable traits,
that group of organisms has evolved.
Over many generations,
small differences in traits
between generations can
add up, and over time,
over thousands to millions of years,
evolution can give rise
to new types of organisms.
For example, over many generations,
one population can evolve
into two different species,
like the rock dove and the hill pigeon.
Even though these two types of birds
look pretty similar to one another,
they are a distinct species
that have been changing along
independent evolutionary paths
for about a million years.
Over the billions of years
that life has existed on Earth,
evolution has given rise
to the amazing diversity
of organisms on our planet.
We have over 10,000 species
of birds alive today,
and there are even more
bird ancestors species that once existed.
Ancestors that were literally dinosaurs,
but, that's a topic for another video.